hi I'm David Baker and I'm a professor
at the University of Washington and I'll
be talking today about protein design
please go ahead and submit questions as
I'm speaking and I'll keep an eye out
for them so the basic premise of the
work onion I described to you is his is
described on this first slide there are
hundreds and thousands not millions of
proteins in nature and these proteins
solve the challenges faced by biological
evolution really exquisitely well so if
you think about problems like capturing
energy from sunlight photosynthesis is
really a miracle of evolution protein is
mediated essentially all the important
functions in our bodies and and our if
you look at a naturally occurring enzyme
for example for coking breaking down
food it works incredibly proficiently
and so basically all the problems which
were faced during biological evolution
are solved it's incredibly well by on
Netflix I wrote eenz however we face
problems now that were not faced during
natural evolution and one could choose
to wait billion years for a set of
proteins to evolve to deal with them
these are the new challenges we face are
things like making new fuel molecules
dealing with carbon fixation new health
challenges that arise these we live
longer now we don't really want to wait
a billion years to solve these problems
and so the basic basic challenge is can
we design a whole new world of synthetic
proteins that solve the that problems we
face today as well as naturally
occurring proteins solve the problems
that were faced during natural evolution
so the basic methods that we use are
based on the on the principle that
proteins fold to their lowest free
energy states so if we want to design
brand-new proteins we have to be capable
to calculate energies reasonably
accurately
and sample protein confirmations
sufficiently to find the global minimum
so for example if we want to make a
protein that folds up to a protein has a
pretty clear shape we need to find an
amino acid sequence for which the lowest
energy structure is the desired
structure if we want to design proteins
with new functions we need to have
hypotheses about the arrangement of
atoms the spatial arrangement that's
necessary to achieve the desired
function for example to catalyze a
chemical reaction or to bind a small
molecule and finally it's very important
to experimentally test all designs
because while we can calculate many many
things our calculations aren't perfect
and solely when we experimentally test
things that we can tell whether arc
whether our calculations were were
correct or not
so the basic workflow for everything I'm
going to tell you about is given here we
start with a cup with a computer
calculation of an optimal sequence for a
desired structure or function and all
outlined how that works in just a moment
since we've designed the protein we know
what its amino acid sequences and we can
simply read the amino acid sequence off
of the design protein we can then take
that amino acid sequence and back
translate it to a DNA sequence and at
this point it's just up to this point
it's just been pure sort of computer
fiction because these are virtual amino
acid sequences that never existed
anywhere but but the really neat thing
is it's written with advances in gene
synthesis DNA has become a commodity
item so we can simply order genes from
companies relatively cheaply that encode
these brand-new design proteins and
currently we're ordering on the order of
a hundred brand new proteins that never
existed a month in the lab and testing
them once we have the proteins once we
have the genes we put them into bacteria
or yeast cells make the proteins and
then see if the proteins do what they
were intended to do so I'm going this
first animation this is the protein
design animation which should start
you
so what you saw on the video the first
video showed you an example of protein
design where the where the backbone was
kept fixed of the protein shown in
ribbon and different combinations of
amino acids were were searched through
searching for a combination which had
the lowest energy in that structure the
the second video showed you the process
of checking to see whether a design
whether the design had whether a
sequence that we designed actually
folded up to the desired structure and
it was showed the process of predicting
the structure of a protein let's see how
do I get this
ok good good ok ok so the I think what
I'll do is go on now and describe the
what we've used these protein design
methods to do and I apologize for not
having explained the videos before they
played I didn't realize I wouldn't be
able to speak while they were running
all right so the first challenge I'm
going describe to you is the design of
new protein structures and here the idea
is that naturally occurring proteins as
I described evolved to carry out
specific functions and almost all
proteins hence have non-ideal features
such as irregular loops or kinked HeLa
sees that result from selection for
function and we were interested in the
question of whether we could design
brand new ideal proteins outside the
constraints of natural evolution and
we've developed a set of design
principles for creating super stable
ideal structures and these proteins have
great advantages for far as platforms
for for future design efforts as I'll
describe so the we chose 5 5 protein
ideal protein structure topologies and
they're listed under the design column
of this slide and these are apologies
which are much simpler than any that
least that of any real protein protein
structures that occur in nature and we
based and we use the calculation shown
in the first video where different amino
acid sequences were being sampled to
find amino acids sequences that are very
low on energy in these structures then
we took those amino acid sequences and
we use the calculation showed in the
second video where the chain
folding up to see what the lowest energy
state for that design sequence was and
the results are shown on the left and
this is actually this is a calculation
done using rosada at home which is a
distributed computing project we run out
of my lab you can volunteer for it
you just go to this Google search
Rosetta at home and basically volunteers
all around the world help us design
proteins by providing spare cycles on
their computers each red dot on this
plot represents the work of a different
individual volunteers computer and what
it represents is the endpoint of a
protein folding calculation on the
y-axis is the energy of that calculated
structure and on the x-axis is the the
distance from the structure we are
trying to design that's the structure
shown in the second column and what you
can see for all five of these sequences
is that the energy drops as the distance
from the desired structure decreases and
the lowest energy structures are very
very close to the desired target
structure so this means that the
sequence we've designed at least on the
computer has a very very strong tendency
to fold up to the desired structure
there's no other possible structures
which are lower in energy so when we see
sequin when we find sequences that have
this property we then order genes that
encode these protease sequences because
we believe based on these calculations
they'll fold up to the desired
structures and that's what we did for
each of these five and then the third
column under NMR shows the structures of
these proteins that were solved by NMR
spectroscopy and the last the fourth and
the fifth column just so as you blow up
so different parts of these structures
and you might be able to see that not
only are the backbones of the model we
were trying to make and the enema
structure nearly perfectly
superimposable but also many of the side
chains aren't exactly at the right place
so we've been able to design here
completely new protein structures that
that fold up
there's amino acid sequence that fold up
to exactly the desired target structure
I should also say that these proteins
are exceptionally stable and that's
because they're really optimized to be
for folding and for stability and at
this point they don't have any function
of course what we're doing now is start
introduce introducing the functionality
into these proteins and we can verify
that as we do this we haven't lost the
door we haven't
disrupted the folding because we run we
can run the calculation shown in the
left cotton level on the leftmost column
that I already went through on the new
sequences that are that are we've been
mutant which which are encode functional
versions of these and make sure that
they still are predicted to fold up to
the correct structure so so that's how
we design brand new structures the next
thing I'll talk about is the design of
molecular recognition and here the steps
are to to start with a travel model of
the protein or small molecule you want
to you want to make a binding protein
that binds to it and then
computationally design proteins are
predicted to bind that target with high
affinity and specificity and then again
make genes that encode the most
promising designs and then make the
proteins or display them on the east
earthís and assess binding by by one of
several experimental methods and I'll
start by this talking about binding
design of binding to protein targets and
the basic idea is outlined here the
target protein is shown in this surface
representation we start by a docking
disembodied amino acids which are the
things shown in sticks onto the surface
in finding places where
these amino acids fit really well this
so you might an analogy would be the
surface you might think of as a climbing
wall and we start by trying to find
handholds and footholds where you can
grab on to the surface
so these disembodied amino acids are
like disembodied hands and feet then the
next step as you could imagine it is to
connect the hands and feet with a body
that holds them together and that would
be a protein scaffold which could be one
of the ideal ones which I just described
which holds these amino acids in exactly
the right arrangement to to to provide
high affinity binding and I'm going to
illustrate this first with the influenza
virus surface protein which is the
protein that's shown in gray on the left
and there are a number of um antibodies
known that find this and they're shown
in the ribbons that sort of that
surround this the problem with the flu
as you know is that it's quite variable
in so every year there's a new strain
there's one region on the virus though
which can't chain it's the one that's
down by where the the yellow virus binds
and so we sought to make a small protein
that could bind to this very very
tightly with the goal of making
something that would neutralize most flu
viruses a blow-up of that site is shown
in the left panel of the slide that's
this cool egg gray you can see this
great cleft and so we use the approach
that I described will redock disembodied
amino acids into this cleft that's shown
on the right different types of amino
acids the pink and purple things are
where the protein backbone that this
disembodied amino acid would have to be
in order for the sidechain to get into
that craft so the the next step is to as
I said find protein scaffolds which can
can hold these amino acids in place and
one such couple such scaffolds are shown
here here in this view the the surface
of the virus is shown in the surface
view and the side chains these handhold
and foot
hold hands and feet are these the side
chains are docked up against the surface
and then in the ribbon ribbon ething is
a design the protein backbone that holds
these in the right place and so we we we
made we carried out many design
calculations and we selected on the
order of I think roughly 80 designs that
look promising
they made jeans and then we measured the
proteins for binding to to be to the
virus and two of them bound quite
tightly those are shown here in yellow
is the viral surface and in pink are the
two design proteins they're called hvad
and HB 36 here and you can see what how
the scaffolds that hold these amino
acids in place are ours are small
helical helical bundles and you can see
that the side chains are being held they
so they fit really perfectly into these
pockets so the I apologize about this so
we of course just because they bind the
virus doesn't mean that they're binding
in the in the correct manner
we've solved crystal structures of these
proteins bound to the virus and they are
virtually identical to the design model
and I can I think you can only see the
one that properly for the one on the
left that was the one that it wasn't
called HB 36 in the previous slide so
the ribbon diagram on the left is the
entire flu viral surface protein called
the hemagglutinin and then the red is
the crystal structure where were in
wearing the experiment in the me and the
actually experimentally determine
structure where this binding protein was
and the purple is in is where it was
supposed to be according to the design
model and then you see a blow-up in the
inset where you can see that not only
was the backbone in the right place but
the side chains are really fitting for
binding the virus
exactly the way they were supposed to
according to the design model and these
the binding proteins bind quite tightly
to the quite a quite a wide range of new
viral strains almost all Group one
influenza viruses this table list within
B gives a list of the different viruses
that defines - including the 1918
Spanish flu that the epidemic had a
number of other pandemic flu strains and
it also the way that what this protein
does is undergo a basic first attaches
to the surface of your cell and then the
flu virus gets taken up and then the pH
drops and then that triggers our
conformational change in this food
protein and that's critical for the
virus to enter your cell cells and these
small proteins block this low pH
conformational change and they actually
protect against the virus and cell
culture so if you you add flu virus to
so two cells and culture it kills them
if you add these flu binding proteins
that neutralizes them so these have
promised as anti-flu therapeutics and
we're currently following up on this to
see if they protect they protect animals
infected with the flu and this is
there's always new flu strain so having
ways of locking the flu is useful the
method that was really general there was
anything specific about about the flu so
in principle should be able to design
binders to any desired surface patch on
a target of known structure and this
could be a general route to to new drugs
these small proteins could have
advantages both over small molecules and
that they can bind more tightly and
specifically and so of less side effects
and they're a lot easier to make than
antibodies which are which are also bind
specifically and have high affinity
they're easier to make these are much
smaller proteins okay now I'm going to
talk about the design of proteins which
bind not a
proteins but instead bind the small
molecules and I'm going to illustrate
the technique with just this molecule
that's shown here the oxy Jenin which is
a protein that's you small molecule it's
used to treat certain types of heart
conditions but it can be given in too
large a dose and so there's a lot of
interest in in making proteins that
would soak up excesses in case of an
overdose so we designed the protein
which has the cavity there's a sort of
shown on the right is the surface muse
the design protein you can see the small
molecule fitting into the cavity and
when we tested this design again we had
to make a number of design the number of
designs to find several that found
tightly we found this protein does bind
the small molecule quite tightly you can
see in the lower panel on the right you
can see the design binding site you see
the small molecule in purple and in
green or the side chains from the design
protein and you can see the hydrogen
bonds that these side chains make with
the small molecule and also how the side
chains pack and form a cavity that's a
complementary to the small molecule we
solved the crystal structure of this
design protein and again it's very
similar bound to the small molecule and
again the binding mode is very similar
to to the design model in red is the
design model what we feel we're trying
to make and in blue is how it actually
binds and you can see that they are
they're very very close again so we're
able to design again this is another
example where you can design like a
recognition with a very high accuracy I
won't go through this side in detail but
this compound belongs to a family of
steroid compounds with fairly similar
structures and by changing the the
detailed sidechain details of the side
chains around this site
by making mutations we can program or
reprogram the specificity of binding of
this design protein to different small
molecules and basically the way that
these steroids differ from each others
by the presence or absence of their
hydroxyl groups which are indicated on
the top right and so by by changing the
side chains which interact with these
hydroxyl groups we can change the
specificity so okay so I've talked about
binding designing protein binding and
designing small molecule binding and now
I'm going to talk about designing
protein based nanomaterials
there are a lot of reasons you might
want to design protein nanomaterials for
example for drug delivery you can
imagine synthetic cages that you can
package small molecules in for vaccines
making synthetic things synthetic
particles that look like viruses but
display the apathy epitopes you want a
vaccine raised against and then
happening from microcircuitry already
there's a lot of different types of
nanomaterials that could be very useful
and one should be also keep in mind that
familiar materials like silk and wool
are made out of protein so if we could
figure out her design proteins this that
bound to each other in very precise ways
really could have a whole new class of
materials for many different purposes so
I've already talked about designing
ideal globular protein building blocks
and now the challenge is lying astraios
how to put these building blocks
together to make nano structures and i'm
not going to go don't have time to go
through the method in detail but suffice
it to say that we start by picking a
particular geometry for example in this
case a cubic geometry and we arranged
the rearranged possible subunits of this
nano structure in the correct relative
geometry to form a cube and sample the
degrees of freedom of the cube which is
basically to imagine for example change
the length changing the size of the cube
and then we used the protein design
calculation I showed you two to design
an interface between these subunits so
that they assemble and stick together in
the right way and well you can see in
the electron micrograph on the bottom
left is our images of this design cube
where we've made the probe we've made
the gene for the into bacteria have made
the protein and you can see that this
protein itself assembled into a cubic
structure as as designed and we will
solve the crystal structure of this
design nano material and like the
previous crystal structures I've shown
you it's virtually identical to to the
design model you can't even really tell
the difference the design models while
they're trying to make some gray and the
crystal structure is in blue and this
just shows you another view the one the
cube I just showed you it was is on the
Left there's a cube has different
symmetry axes and this just shows use
down the different symmetry axis of the
design model and the crystal structure
which I showed you before they're very
similar
here's another one which is tetrahedral
and again the design is very similar to
the crystal structure we've now extended
these methods to allow us to make
nanomaterials composed of more than one
component and this just shows how we how
we do it again we have to choose the
symmetry and this one is kinda neat this
is two inverted tetrahedra which you can
see in the top left have a panel and we
arrange subunits
the blue subunit and the green subunit
are they're going to be the components
of these two inverted cut reader and
then we slide them relative to each
other as shown panel B and rotate them
until we find a way in which they really
fit nicely together and then we design
the interface between them and that
shown in E where we've done the design
calculation to get a very complimentary
interface and then we make the proteins
and we can identify using a native gel
those designs where we've made those
cases where
two proteins in the same cell and where
these proteins are coming as sticking
together to form a high order assembly
and actually I'll go back on the right
you see you see what happens if you if
you if you what a chromatogram of the
cell lysate looks like from these two
protein when with these these two
proteins here are are co-expressed these
are designed proteins and this is on a
sizing column and their Co purifying
here suggesting they're sticking
together and this just shows sizing
column data showing that they do stick
together in solution but the really neat
thing is when you look at electron
micrographs of these purified assemblies
they look it's a little hard to see here
because it's small but these shapes of
these purified particles are very
similar to to what we were to the design
models and we've been able to solve
crystal structures of four of them and
again these are very similar so these
are just two different views of four
different designs and so for example on
the top left you have the design model
two different views down different
symmetry axes for this design t3 3-15
and then the crystal structure is
virtually identical to this and that's
true for the one for example on the
right called t 33 - 28 this penny
shape and again that's almost perfectly
recapitulated in the in the crystal
structure which is shown underneath so
we can make these two component
materials with very high accuracy and
these are quite neat because you can
imagine it's very easy now to package
small molecules for example inside them
because these these cages can't assemble
until both components are present we can
also put put different things on the
outside for example if we want to
I make vaccines these assemblies are
closed so they're there they're closed
cages but we can use exactly the same
methods now to make open two dimensional
and three dimensional arrays and we have
some nice examples now open a rat to do
two-dimensional lattices so we're very
excited about making a whole new class
of materials using these methods and yes
on this slide I just show a blow-up of
the side chains at the at the interfaces
of one of these designs and again
they're very close to where they were
supposed to be okay so now I'm going to
end my talk by describing something a
little different and but I thought that
you might find it interesting I
described a project called Rosetta at
home where we send up the computer
program we've developed for these
calculations called rosetta out to
volunteers all over the world who can
enlist and they contribute spare time on
their computers and that's in fact how
most of the calculations I told you
about are being done so I encourage you
to sign up for Rosetta at home and then
you can also always see what we're doing
because the screensaver that place will
fill you the calculations we're trying
to make and for example for these
symmetric assemblies that are really
pretty to watch anyway so was at home
participants were looking at the
watching the screen savers and they
started thinking that they might be able
to do better so I got started getting
messages from participants saying well
can you make some way for us to interact
with we can see with computers doing and
we think that is not doing the right
thing
can't we we'd like to be able to go in
there and guide it
so we developed a game called directed
game called Foldit which is basically
like reside at home except that given
the game player can go in and move and
sort of override the computer by by
pushing them pulling the protein in
different ways and the really neat thing
over the past couple years is that game
players people in the general public can
I have made some really neat scientific
advances and I'll tell you briefly about
them now
so the first one involves structure
determination and I'm not going to go
through this slide in detail just
suffice to say that we've been
developing methods I didn't really have
time to talk about for solving protein
structures more effectively not only
when you have no data but when you have
some data for example some of the x-ray
crystallographic data but not that's not
sufficient to to solve the structure
using conventional methods so we had
until people all around the world
starting sending us problems they were
stuck on where they had crystallographic
data but they couldn't solve the
structure and many many of them we were
able to solve and we publish the paper
that cited here showing that we have his
new method for solving hard problems but
we also got a data set that we weren't
able to solve and so in desperation we
get aside up for folded players to try
and solve and this was a retro viral
protease and it was quite an interesting
protein there had been a lot of work on
it it was supposed to there's a full bit
puzzle this is a little bit out of date
um well after we tried it out in the lab
and we weren't able to solve it using
our conventional methods we gave it to
folded players and this is what the fold
it looks like this is the this was the
the protein in Foley again you can you
have access to all of the standard those
other functionalities which are which
are given name non-technical names like
wiggle and shake those are basically the
two animations I showed you and you can
move and pull on it I encourage you to
go to fold it and you can try it out for
yourself there's introductory levels to
help you use it anyway um what happened
is is is shown here the to give away two
punch line the folded players were able
to solve the structure it's shown in
blue here it wasn't known before and
Foldit players formed teams it's really
cool here this in this case the the
first player started with starting with
this we had a rough model which we knew
wasn't right red we gave that
to them and you can see it's quite
different from the blue model the first
player SP Vincent produced the yellow
model which is quite a bit better than
the starting red model it's closer to
the blue then pass it off to his
teammate grab Horn who who made it still
better still closer to the blue you can
see if directly in the site in the core
of the protein you see now see some of
these side chains coming closer and
closer and then grab one passed off to
me me who who improved it still further
and when we got the solution back from
Mimi we can look at the fit to the
experimental data which wasn't
sufficient you couldn't you couldn't saw
in the structure using the data but it's
kind of like a fingerprint you could
tell whether you had it right and you
can see that that ninis solution well
what we could see is that it clearly fit
the data much better than anything we've
seen before and when we send it back to
the experimentalists who we solved it
who were working on the problem they
could see immediately is the correct
solution so this was really neat so fold
the players and solve the structure
which had eluded structured information
for a long time
the next example I want to give is we
were very curious about hopeful that
players were we're doing these amazing
things and so we thought we would just
find I so I emailed a bunch of really
tough top older players asked them what
they were doing and they wrote back very
calm very sophisticated things I
realized that wasn't going to be easy to
find the common element of really
successful strategies so instead we gave
we developed a method for folded players
to encode their own algorithms in this
in a strips called recipes and when we
made this available to folded players we
found so several years ago now that the
number of us pulled the players
developed a massive number of recipes
and they're shown in the this bar graph
here shows for each week how many
recipes we use and each distinct shade
along a bar represents a different
recipe and the width of the recipe
indicates how often it's used so if
you're a sharing type of holder player
you make your recipes available to other
then lots of people use them and if
you're more of a private person you keep
them to yourself in which case you're
the only one who uses them and you have
a narrower bar when when we noticed over
time was that there were two recipes
that really started taking over the
population they're the ones shown in in
red and in green and these have quite
nice names this one's called cool
Redskins quakin that blue and green ones
of blue fuse so we're really curious
what they were and what we were really
surprised at is that when we looked at
what the players had come up with there
was astonishingly similar design that we
had developed over the same period of
time unpublished and as Isis my group
had been developing it and it was really
uncanny how similar it was so the former
players had basically discovered the
same thing we had but of course they
weren't they weren't professional
biophysics you know our computational
biologists like we are but they'd come
up with the same thing and turns out
their algorithm blue fuse is actually
better in the context of the game than
what we had developed so so we're very
excited now to follow the the new
algorithms that players are developing
as we can see they can develop things
which are at least as good as what we
can hear then the final example is a
protein design example and I didn't talk
about it but we've done we'll use the
methods I described design neurons and
catalysts that catalyze reactions which
aren't catalyzed by naturally occurring
proteins I told you at the beginning
that one of the things proteins do is
catalyze reactions like breaking down
food in your stomach and they do all
sorts of amazing things there's some
reactions that don't they don't catalyze
and one of them is shown here this is in
the left panel the two purple small
molecules in this reaction are linked by
can be linked by two carbon-carbon bonds
in sign called a diels-alder reaction
which is catalyzed by naturally
occurring enzymes so in brown you see a
designed enzyme that we use the methods
describe to design and this holds those
two purple molecules to the right
relative orientation for carbon-carbon
bond formation in the form and when we
mate we made a number of different
designs and we found one that catalyzed
the reaction then that's shown in the
right you see the amount of this product
formed as a function of time and you see
the so the good thing is that this
reaction is no known enzyme that
catalyzes a reaction we've made
something that clearly catalyzes it like
most of the designed enzymes we made
however the it's a poor enzyme so this
is at this timescale of hours not
seconds as you would like it to be for
naturally occurring enzyme or for good
Anna's on faster is better so we chose
this as a as a challenge to for the
players could they actually make it
better and so this shows the crystal
structure of the design which again as
in the other cases was very similar to
the design model and you can see it's in
the ribbon here and the two small
molecules are shown in the centre and
you can see one reason why this is not a
very good enzyme is that the lower of
the small modulus is really small and
it's not really very bound very tightly
by the enzyme it's a very open active
site so we wondered if there was some
way of making a holding on these ligands
better and so this is what we asked the
folded community to do and they came up
with this radical solution by inserting
this big long loop in in the middle of
in the middle of the protein you can see
a sort of comes over and it holds these
small molecules in place where they're
supposed to be this loop has with this
insertion the the protein has an 18-volt
greater catalytic activity than the
starting design which is really quite
impressive and so we were very excited
about this the Foldit players had done
something really remarkable and then
when we solved the the crystal structure
of this protein it was even more amazing
because the crystal structure was very
similar to what they designed
and so so this shows that that
non-scientists candy can not only help
solve protein structures but they can
also they can also design new proteins
so if you go to fold it and start
playing you will be able to help us with
their design efforts and you know if we
like your designs will go and make them
and you will be an author on our on the
papers that come out of them and so
we're really excited about getting more
people involved in doing this kind of
research the types of the folded
problems that design problems now that
you'll see if you go there are designing
new types of symmetric assemblies like
such as the ones that I described so
I've been really fortunate to have a lot
many many wonderful collaborators who
are listed here who actually did the
work on I didn't really do much of
anything myself so so I think now at
this point I will look at the questions
that have been appearing and and see
what I can say about them what do I do
yeah okay all right so let's see how do
I get is there's number three and number
four how do I
maybe there is there one before this ok
I so ok sorry so I see two questions
which have numbers three and four the
first one is can we build these designs
involve it to be delivered as an
antibody well what we are these exactly
so these proteins that were designing
you can you could could be delivered in
just the same way that you would deliver
an antibody and in fact that's what we
are working towards both with these
anti-flu designs and we're also
designing proteins to hit tumor cell
targets and proteins involved in
autoimmune responses and so once we've
designed these proteins verified that
they bind their targets and and shown
that they have the correct in vitro cell
culture properties then the next steps
are to do animal tests the same kind of
things you would do in evolving an
antibody as a therapeutic the advantage
of these molecules over antibodies is
that they can be made at very high
levels in e.coli
and some of them are small enough that
they can be chemically synthesized which
takes a lot of the cost out of protein
therapeutic manufacturer so now the next
question is do we have information on
the potential toxicity of the design
cages well one obvious question concern
is that they may elicit immune response
and in work I didn't describe we've
developed methods for designing out
t-cell epitopes to reduce the
immunogenicity of the designs and we
have some results not on these
particular cages but on other protein
successes justing we can successfully
reduce the immunogenicity of design
proteins but I think each case we will
have this will have to be checked
carefully now
question is can you help can you help
design an inhibitor if we don't have the
crystal structure but the active site is
part of the known family well let's see
design is if you have an accurate if you
have a structure of what you're trying
to design a binding binder to it's much
better if you the active if the protein
is part of a known family then you can
you can do the model of the target
protein and then using that model design
try and design inhibitor but the success
rate will be lower so that's all the
questions I have currently all this way
to wait a minute to see if there any
others and if not at all thank you for
your attention
let's see okay good so I got a couple
more more questions so are there similar
active site shapes with designed enzymes
related to other approaches like
catalytic antibodies that's a good
question so the kanima canta bodies are
little different in that first of all
they're not they were designed they
weren't really designed by a computer
there was a selection that was used for
for the antibodies to bind a transition
state analog so they were they were
obtained by an approach more like
natural evolution so the active site
shapes tend to be different because in a
catalog antibody they're made up of the
active site loops whereas in these
designed enzymes they tend to be more
pockets like in naturally occurring
enzymes so but as a whole me the
approaches are somewhat complementary P
is what can start with using a
calculation to get a design
activity and then use evolutionary
approaches laboratory evolutionary
approaches to increase the activity and
in fact that in every case we've
designed an enzyme on a computer it's
been possible to evolve it to make it
higher infinity to make it more active
by random selection the design gives you
the starting point okay next question is
can we use your approach to noble design
CDRs and build the antibody the answer
is yes people are using Rosetta the
program I described to design CDRs and
build antibodies in fact most major
pharma companies have licensed Rosetta
from the University of Washington to do
exactly well to do many things but among
them - to design antibodies okay then
how long does it take to solve the
structure crystal structure of an enzyme
well that depends on the hard part is
getting crystals if you can get your
enzyme to salt to form crystals then
then then it's actually quite
straightforward to solve the structure
the next question is how does one design
a t-cell epitopes to reduce
immunogenicity
okay so there's large data sets of four
different MHC alleles the the peptide
binding specificities are known
experimentally and we use these these
databases during the design process to
avoid peptide sequences which which bind
to MHC alleles and so so if a peptide
sequence binds is known to bind or as
close to similar something that binds to
a MHC we we disfavor it during their
design and Congress lis if it's similar
to or is identical to a peptide sequence
that occurs in the human genome we give
it a bonus okay let's see I'm getting so
many so many questions now I think I'm
going to have to pick and choose
okay how we used our approaches to
successfully design protein-protein
interaction disruption yes we have so we
have designed a number of proteins that
that will bind to that bind to their
targets and block binding of the natural
liquor not naturally occurring protein
so this is something that is quite an
advantage of design protein as well as
opposed to a small molecule it is hard
to make small molecules that disrupt
protein protein interactions but we can
design proteins that disrupt that
disrupt disrupt protein protein
interactions and so we have quite a few
examples now of basically the trick is
we just designed saying it has higher
affinity for the target than the
naturally occurring partner does so when
we add this design protein it will
displace the naturally occurring protein
okay lots of good questions here okay so
this is a good question it says your
successes are impressive but the false
positive rate is high the false positive
right is very very high and so the real
question is can we distinguish the ones
that are correct from the ones that are
incorrect well obviously this is
something that we're working on hard we
and the good thing is we're continually
getting more data on this one of the
things that's the most that's
particularly useful is the scent of
reorganization of the design site in the
unbound State
so what we what we do for example a
powerful metric is what we call the is
essentially the Boltzmann weight of the
design sidechain say in the active site
of an enzyme rather than active site of
a design small molecule binding site if
the design if those amino acids the side
chains that compose the site are
predicted to be really locked in place
there's a much higher probability that
the design will be is successful so we
are
the answer is of course we would like to
have a hundred percent success with our
designs and we're certainly getting a
lot of data on how to do things
incorrectly because we have but but
we're definitely observing trends and
it's an interesting it's an interesting
problem classification problem in itself
you know given that we have many many
different designs for a number of
different problems now the challenge is
to distinguish what what you know it's
English so the thing is that once that
word from the ones that don't as I
mentioned that that's sort of the pre
organization of the binding site the
extent to which the protein really folds
up to the design model is seems to be
among our among the best discriminator
so far okay let's see okay what are the
best simulators of protein folding well
if you want to predict protein structure
probably the best method to use is the
is Rosetta the program we've developed
over the years for protein structure
prediction but if you want to actually
simulate the folding process then what
the dynamics is it is a better method
and there there's very impressive
results from the Shaw with specialized
purpose computing doing very long time
simulations the real problem with
molecular dynamic simulations is just
that it takes a huge amount of computing
time all right if you increase that okay
here's a good question all these are
good questions if you increase
throughput of contract generation
screening will you even further ensure
an even higher success rate the answer
is yes because it's probabilistic
unfortunately this design process is not
it is one of probabilities you know we
have for any given problem we have a
certain chance of success the more
constructs we can make and screen the
better and as you know the cost of gene
synthesis keeps decreasing and so even
if we didn't get any smarter and better
which hopefully we will well I guess if
we even if our methods didn't get better
our success rate would get higher as we
could for our success rate that is our
chance of getting an active design would
go up
our real goal is to make the whole
process much to be able to automatically
to computationally discriminate the
designs that work from those that don't
so we all don't even or make jeans for
the ones that don't work I don't know
anything about mosaics for the question
person who asked about that threw out an
idea now on what surfaces or what
situations we can't design for very
charged surfaces are hard
most of the lot of the affinity and what
their interactions comes from nonpolar
interactions and those tend to be things
that those are easy to design - need
binders towards very charged surfaces
are much more challenging because you
have to get perfect complementarity
hydrogen bond donors and acceptors yeah
so okay so here's a question about
flexibility many enzymes use flexibility
to order transitions during the
catalytic reaction have we included this
well that's an it with naturally
occurring enzymes which are really
mastered that the chemical
transformation part of the problem then
the problem comes how you get the
substrate in and the product out and so
flexibility becomes very important and
in our case I think we do have
flexibility but it's some flexibility of
the sort that's not really helping I
mentioned that a good discriminator of
designs which are active from designs
which aren't is is how well rocked in
place the catalytic side chains are so I
think our problem right now is too much
of the wrong kind of flexibility and
after we can really pin down the side
chains where we're supposed to be we can
start thinking about putting in the
right kind of flexibility you know
thoughts of things were looping out of
the way to get a substrate released and
so forth we do see product product
release as being rate limiting in some
of our designs so even now some
flexibility in the right way could be
better
let me just look through let's see
there's a question about nucleic acid
design using Rosetta so we have
developed so Rosetta we have developed
Rosetta to design nucleic acid
structures and that work is now be
continued by people within my group -
now left for example Phil Bradley and
Jim Hobart at Fred Hutchinson and
Washington wash you working on protein
DNA interactions and review das working
on RNA structure modeling at Stanford
let's see
oh hi dream do you have examples of
designs that bind in at least something
well we have our proteins that binds
small molecules do release them and then
of course the enzymes bind substrates
and then release products which are
which are transformed let's see let's
see there's a question about I mentioned
four angstrom ish structures and fitted
models to them showing our misty's
around 0.7 angstroms let's see that
question I'm not sure what it's
referring to in when we for the work
we've done on molecular replacement we
start with we can start with quite poor
models say for inks from five eggs from
resolution and naturally solve
structures with them in some cases using
the improvement after replacement
methods one thing I didn't talk about
that's very exciting now is
cryo-electron microscopy based structure
determination and we can use cryo-em
density in just the same way to guide
our structure prediction methods so it
develops some very exciting methods for
taking low resolution cryo-em density
and generating quite high
models let's see right so uh Shree we've
the question about membrane can we
design membrane proteins and what are
the challenges well that's a it's a very
interesting question I think that in
many ways it should be easier to design
membrane proteins and soluble proteins
there's a lot more constraints the
problem really is in the experimental
testing and that's something that can't
be underestimated because because you
have to you know just doing the
computational design is one part but
then you have to be able to test and the
problem with a membrane protein is that
you you you make the protein in say a
bacterium you have to get it insert into
a membrane and a relatively pure form so
and then the structural biology as much
is is much harder so I emphasized and
throughout my talk the crystal
structures and comparisons of the
structures to the designs is you really
need that to know whether you're on the
right track or not so it's harder to
make the membrane proteins to get them
in pure form and it's harder to
determine their structures so I would
say the problems with designing membrane
proteins are almost entirely on the
experimental side work on doing myself
valued and talked about is designing
long helical bundles which look
undesigned soluble versions of these
I've been able to do this make very
stable things with very high accuracy
and it would be quite easy to use these
methods to design membrane proteins
again just the experimental
characterization becomes much more
difficult
is there any hope that some day in the
future we can computationally calculate
the structure of a protein from a DNA
sequence yes I think there is and as I
mentioned with with being a child before
very small peptides have shown that with
long time long ago dynamic simulations
you can get quite accurate structures
and there's a protein structure
prediction experiment called CASP that
runs every two years where we and other
people participate and you can see that
the predictive structures can in
somebody's cases be quite accurate it's
it's low probability but even now with
Rosetta for example some fraction of the
time
an ab initio predictive structure can be
quite accurate it's it's too unreliable
to be used really to be very useful at
this point but the methods keep getting
better in computer speak getting you
more powerful so I think it's a
possibility
so there's question about using small
angle x-ray scattering for model
validation and that's that's useful when
the model has a non spherical a quite
non spherical shape and so I think it
could be very useful and in fact I would
be great to have a collaborator stand in
doing this because we we have made we're
making now many things are quite non
spherical and so if you're interested
let me know so I think it I think it
could be quite useful for validating
sort of say they say extended
cylindrical structures such as the ones
I'm designing now
hey there's a question about designing a
protein structure that had designing an
enzyme that that converts a drug that
might be toxic into its active form that
would be like an enzyme that would
convert a pro drug to its to its final
active state and I think that that's
certainly an exciting application for
for for enzyme design
I think it's noon so I should probably
wrap up now so thanks everybody for the
listening